by the simons institute for the theory
of computing my name is peter bartlett
i'm the associate director of the
summers institute
we're a collaborative research institute
in theoretical computer science
funded since 2012 by the simons
foundation and we run two programs each
semester
typically they attract 60 to 70
long-term visitors each
and include a boot camp and three
workshops
and of course those involve many more
people this semester we're hosting two
programs
entirely online so far probability
geometry and computation in high
dimensions
and this one the theory of reinforcement
learning and together they're involving
around
200 participants so welcome to the first
workshop
of the rl program deep reinforcement
learning
uh uh a big thank you to
our events coordinator ashley hassan for
all her work on the logistics
uh to omit fire our videographer
and rit expert drew mason for all the
zoom arrangements
if you have questions for the speakers
please use the zoom q
a feature also a big thank you to the
organizers li hong li and mark bell pair
for
doing a fantastic job in putting
together the program for this week's
workshop
it looks quite exciting and i'll hand
over to li hong to say a few words about
about the workshop earth's themes
have we lastly ah there we go good
i'm here yep thanks peter um can you see
the screen
yes okay great
yeah so um welcome everyone um thanks
for uh
thanks peter um welcome to the um deep
learning
deep reinforcement learning workshop
organized by mark bellmail and myself
the workshop is part of the fall program
on theory of reinforcement learning
which will have two more workshops in
the coming months
we would like to thank the simons
institute for the great support that
makes the workshop possible
especially during this unusual time when
all events have become online
moreover we would like to thank you the
audience for joining us in these virtual
times
and hope you enjoy the workshop it seems
not
okay yep um so what is the workshop
about
um if you look at the current rio
literature you
probably find two types of reinforcement
learning
one of them looks at simpler models such
as tabular or
linear representations and develops
pretty thorough theoretical
understanding
the other which is very popular in
recent years
uses complex models such as neural
networks to
achieve many problems empirical
successes
however the theoretical understanding of
the latter is
much more limited and this is what the
workshop is about
it focuses on theoretical problems
inspired by deep
oriole in practice it provides a forum
to connect practitioners and
theoreticians
to share state of the art in empirical
studies
and to motivate interesting open
theoretical problems
several topics will be covered as we'll
see shortly
this is a five-day workshop we plan to
spend each day on a particular
theme including um
sorry taking a little bit slowly okay
this is a five-day workshop
we plan to spend each day on a
particular theme
including offline reinforcement learning
exploration
optimization representation and
uncertainty modeling
the technical sessions of each day runs
from
9 00 a.m to noon berkeley time including
invited talks and open-ended discussions
each talk or discussion session will be
30 minutes long from noon to 1 pm we'll
have an informal social and get a town
for workshop participants
we hope you enjoyed to find the workshop
interesting and inspiring
now i'm going to turn the presentation
over to mark so that he can start the
first session of the workshop
thanks all right fantastic thank you lee
lihong
um leon if you don't mind moving one
slide forward
um all right it's a it's a real treat to
have all of you here
uh this is uh this is an exciting uh
time to be doing reinforcement learning
especially deep reinforcement learning
and um i think the topic we'll see today
on uh
offline reinforcement as it's now called
is is indeed quite
quite a hot topic so i'm excited to hear
from all of our speakers
um leon already covered the schedule so
without further ado i think we'll just
start
uh with uh tenuma on model-based
offline policy optimization so uh
pleased to
tell you
cool um
[Music]
let me share the slice again
you cannot um leon you may not have to
stop sharing your screen
yeah i cannot share your screen where
others are
okay cool um shall we just get started
now
okay cool uh yeah thanks for uh coming
thanks for the introduction uh this is
john to work with uh tianku
kevin yu on gary thomas and how you
stefano erman james zoe uh circuit 11
and chelsea finn i'm tony ima from
stanford university i guess everyone
else
is also from santa fe university except
sergey who is from
berkeley so um this is um about
model based offline policy optimization
so um i guess um uh let me start with
the
kind of the motivation of studying
offline or at least my motivation of
studying offline oreo
so i guess the bigger picture is that
you know there's a simple efficiency
challenge
in applying rl to many of the real world
applications okay as we all know that
rl is about 12-cent hours so the
technical
flow is that you say i'm going to try
the current strategy and collect
feedbacks and then i'm going to
use the feedbacks to improve the
strategy so this is a
child and iris you know it's very good
and we know that we know
how to solve this using this to self-go
for example
as long as we can try millions of games
in a computer however
in reality if you use this for um
robotics or self-driving cars then
potentially you may have the problem
that
there are not in many enough samples you
can collect from the real environment
just because of some physical
constraints of for some safety
constraints
so i guess you know the question is how
do we reduce the amount of trials the
amount of samples we need
to implement rl in the real applications
i guess well the idea is model-based rl
which is considered to be a promising
direction
to reduce the sample complexity and
another one is offline area which i'm
going to find
uh in a moment and also there are many
other ways for example meta
multi-task lifelong continue rl which
are ways to
amortize the cost and maybe hierarchical
which you know could also be a way to
reduce the sample
complexity so i guess in this talk i'm
going to talk about offline rl and
approach is model based
so hi guys you know in a nutshell
offline hour is about that
you don't have the trials and hours you
cannot collect feedbacks from the
uh the real environment by trying your
strategy so formally
uh the definition of offline arrow is as
follows
so sometimes it's also called batch
reinforcement learning so we are given a
batch
of data a batch of collection of
contradictories sampled from some policy
pi b
sometimes we call this policy behavior
policy and sometimes it's actually
collected from a mixture of
different policies and this you know
collection of trajectories is sampled
you know from the real environment the
true dynamics t
star and we have this kind of we start
from s0
and we execute this policy high b and
get
structures and we also see some rewards
which is assumed to be known without
loss of generality
in this talk just because you can always
fold the reward in the dynamics
and our goal is to learn policy that
maximizes expected return
on the real environment their expected
return is just the sum of the
return over time and then with the
expectation over
the randomness of the initial states and
also the randomness of the policy pi
so here offline really means that we
don't have any additional interactions
with the real environment
so after you see this trajectory of
samples then you cannot interact with
the real environment
so um it's well known that they're this
you know so-called
distributional this european shift issue
for offline reinforcement learning
uh this is roughly speaking that um
anything you learn
from the badge oh you can learn the
model you can learn the
q function anything you learn from the
badge only guarantees actual predictions
accurate predictions on the batch data
distribution the extrapolation to
outside the batch data execution is not
guaranteed
so and if you execute your policy you'll
learn some policies that have to go
outside of
bachelor distribution then there's a
domain shift issue
for example uh this sometimes this you
know domain shift could be damaging for
example if you learn
your q function on a badge and then it
may overestimate
a queue function outside the support of
the batch here is a simple experiment so
you have um
we have a great world example so you
have a initial state at zero the unique
initial state and also there is a unique
goal and you can go left you know
up upward in the leftward you know
rightward so and so forth
and um we have some batch data which is
only a single trajectory
from the source uh from the initial uh
target to the
uh so the initial state to the goal and
um if you learn um and here the reward
is minus one
so if not reaching a goal so that means
that uh if your either goal then your
reward is
on zero and otherwise your reward the
optimal value function
is minus distance to the goal so
however uh here i'm what i'm plotting
here is the heat map of the learned
value function
if you learn on the batch data the value
function um
using either kind of spell my equation
or some color approach
then what you see is that um the uh the
value function learned
the heat map here shows that the value
function is pretty correct
on the batch actually you know we verify
that it's very small error on the badge
however the um the value function
wrongly extrapolates outside the batch
you can see that the value function
actually linearly extrapolates
so the largest value function is
obtained
on the top left corner which is clearly
wrong because the
large value should be either go so
the extra extrapolation outside b
is wrong and this you know is damaging
because if you use this value function
to induce some policy even assume that
um
you have the true dynamics if you use
this value function then you're gonna
just follow the arrows
then you're gonna go to the top left
corner instead of to go
so a common idea to deal with this
domain shift or distribution shift
issue is that what i call as
strong passive pessimism or strong
conservatism i'm just inviting this word
for
contrasting with the slightly milder
conservatives
i'm going to talk about in this talk so
basically the idea is that
you should stay inside the support of
the batch data distribution um
in other words you only want to visit
those states that you are very certain
about
so this is kind of the basic idea um
in many of the prior works uh here so
bcq bear
black these are model freight approach
which tries to restrict
the action to be close to the action
that we have seen
and vince and cql these are trying to
penalize the
either the value function or the q
function outside the batch data
distribution so i guess the question
that we are
asking here one of the motivating points
for us to design an algorithm
is that we're asking whether we can risk
leaving the support of the batch data
in exchange for higher return maybe
sometimes you know
you want to really leave the support of
the batch data because there's a better
approach
to achieve the uh solve the problem
achieve the goal
so however we are less certain about
leaving the support we have to take the
risk
and how can we balance the risk in
exchange uh for higher possible return
so um i'm going to you know demonstrate
the main idea of the talk you know which
is actually very simple on a
simple toy case the offline martian
bandit problem
so this is a dramatic simplification but
actually it turns out that it's
it's almost the same as the offline
reinforced learning at least from the
talk
from the perspective of this talk so
this is basically my um mandate
but you can only pull your arm on once
this is kind of like you are thinking
you are
uh you are doing the last uh bat in the
casino and you have to really go home
after this
um so uh you cannot collecting uh you
cannot do any trials and hours anymore
i'm not going to use the casino as
example i'm going to use yelp so
yeah there are four restaurants let's
say um
you have you know some you know batch
data uh some past reviews
for these four restaurants let's assume
that the reviews are independent
and now you have to choose one
restaurant to go you want to maximize
the
you know make your uh maximize the the
taste
maximize the stars of the restaurant so
um so here you know i have been i'm
having this kind of like dramatic
situation where
for some restaurant you only have one
reviews and for some other restaurants
you have 10k reviews
and they have different mean uh uh stars
so if you apply the strong conservatism
kind of like
approach to this multi uh unbending
problem
in offline setting so that means that
you should consider
to stay in the support of the bachelor
distribution
of course the support is a well you know
it's not a well-defined notion in some
sense because it's not robust
to any small perturbation so i'm
interpreting the support here as that
you need to have you know enough density
uh um in the batch data this is also
what uh
practically speaking the the prior work
is trying to
use so you need to stay in the support
in the uh approximately part
where the density is sufficient large so
let's say suppose you
have to only consider those you know
restaurants with probability
at least two percent in the batch data
and then i'm designing this so that you
know
if you make the two percent cutoff you
have to only choose restaurant four
because that's the only
restaurant with more than two percent uh
of the reviews in the back state and
that means you can only choose
restaurant for only for restaurant four
you have sufficient
data for to be certain
however what we are going to do is that
we are going to be a little milder
we are going to be a little less
conservative by considering
treating off the risk with the return so
um so what we do so we have to
characterize the risk
right so we say i'm going to compute the
confidence interval
uh for each of the restaurant here i'm
getting these numbers by assuming the
arrow bar is
proportional to one over square root of
n actually i'm assuming the arrow bar is
exactly plus minus one over squared just
for the sake of
simplicity and then you get this upper
uh
confidence bound and lower confidence
bound for each of the restaurant
and then what we do is that we maximize
the lower confidence
um bound of of this by
five restaurant so you take the action
which maximize the lower confidence
interval
so confidence bond and then we get
restaurant two
which in some sense guarantees the um
you know
some trade-offs between the risk and
return right so
um this is basically a main idea of this
uh of this paper so
um so here is a super trivial for
material band-aid and the only thing we
have to do is to extend this to
um reinforcement learning so back to
offline reinforced learning so basically
the main idea
is the same so the first step is that we
build a certain qualification
of the return so we say we want to make
sure eta star pi
this is the true return on the true
dynamics
to be in some interval uh you can hide
pi plus minus
e of pi and then after you get this a
certain quantification you say i'm going
to maximize the lower
confidence bound uh it had pi minus e of
pi
and then um
then that's that's the two steps so
basically this is uh uh
what this talk is about uh and i'm going
to describe
describe a little bit how do i do step
one and step two is pretty simple
basically you just apply some
optimization
algorithm optimizing over the policy so
how do we build a certain classification
for the return
uh we are taking a model based approach
meaning that
um we are starting from the anthony
convocation for learning dynamics
and then we trans we translate that
uncertain quantification
for the dynamics to and certificate
uncertainty classification for the
return
so we don't know how to do the answer
signification for the learned dynamics
in a principled way this is a very
difficult way
different question so any answer
modification with nonlinear model is
difficult
but we assume we have a building block
or module
or kind of oracle to have an
identification for the learn dynamics
and then we turn that into a certain
quantification
for the return of the policy so how do
we do that
we learn a dynamical model t hat on the
batch data
which is assumed to be deterministic for
the moment i'm going to extend it to
star caster case as well
so and we also assume that the learning
so because learning dynamical model is
surprised
so we assume that the surprise learning
algorithm also comes with a calibrated
guarantee
calibration guarantee so assume that
there exists an arrow estimator we can
obtain an arrow estimator u
for the uh dynamics t hat satisfying
that the arrow estimator u is admissible
in the sense that it's indeed
an upper bound for the real error so t
hat minus t
star the norm of t hat and c star so
this is our assumption on the
calibration of the model and then we
also assume that the value function
v pi t star is the ellipsis uh i'm going
to expand on this a little bit
um on in the next slide but basically
you have to assume something about your
value function
oh because you know you have to assume
something about the reward function
right if the reward can be
plus minus infinity then there's no uh
uh chance that you can
do anything offline because the reward
at some other you know state you have to
see
you haven't seen could be just a plus
infinity or negative infinity and then
with these assumptions
we can prove that you have some external
quantification
so um this is um
a confidence bound for eta star so eta
star is in
either had pi plus minus e of pi and e
of pi
is equals to this quantity it's a scalar
c gamma
c gamma over one minus gamma times
the expectation of usa the expectation
of the arrow estimator
over on the trajectories sampled from
the policy pi and the learn dynamics t
hat
so so this error estimator uh so this
e pi is something we can compute
ourselves if we have the iris meter u
and also the policy pi and t hat
so i guess i see
a question is the the right thing to do
to answer the question right now
um go ahead and answer it that's fine
sure okay
yeah so uh the question is is it
maximizing the lower bound
confidence bound kind of exploration
versus exploitation
uh dilemma while being conservative with
the lower bound only
so i guess uh here um you know this is a
very good question so why we are
optimizing
uh the lower confidence bound so uh it
sounds like this is still very
conservative i agree
this is still very conservative we are
just treating off
uh with the return a little bit uh and
um part of the reason we do this is that
this is something
um this guarantees that we can have a
lower bound for the real return
um but potentially there could be better
ways to do it
um i i will discuss this probably more
at the end uh in the open questions
can you where will stop i'll just say
you have about five minutes left on the
talk itself and then we can
discuss some of these final points also
sure
sounds good so um
okay so this is basically the uh the how
do we do the answer identification so
um we use the iso and configuration for
the dynamics and turn it into a
simplification for the right
term uh and you can also have a unified
approach for starter custom dynamics
you know um so here what we do is that
this this page is a little bit abstract
but bear with me for a moment so we
assume that
the value function belongs to some c
times a scalar times the family of
uh functions capital f uh and we assume
some error estimator
uh in a slightly different form so
assume that because this is um
uh um um now stochastic dynamics then t
of s a and key star of sa are uh
random variables or distributions so
then we measure the quality of the
dynamics by estimate um by measuring
the the distance between keys as a
anti-star of sa
and here the distance is the integral
probability metric
ipn between the two distributions with
respect to f and we want that the
average meter to be upper bound of that
um so just uh to remind you that the ipm
is a
way to measure the distance between two
distributions
via the test function f belonging
belonging to the family capital f right
so you look at the expectation of f
under the two distributions you take the
differences and then you take the sub
over all the test functions
and this allows us to unify us a few
different cases
for example if you assume v pi t star is
elliptious
then the distance is the voice of the
distance i know the dynamic is
deterministic then the distance is just
l2 distance
and if we pi t star is bounded and the
distance is tv distance
and if we had t star is some kind of
kernel space then
df could be the maximum mean discrepancy
distance
so uh with this we can prove us um
almost the same you know result um um
but just a
more general assumption so it's the same
basically the same
guarantee so we know that e of pi of the
same form
is our estimator for the true return
uh i guess i'm going to escape the
improved sketch you know i'm just going
to flash it you know
because i have limited time so the proof
sketch is very simple actually this is
you know
has been done in many prior work as well
so basically you're just trying to build
the upper bound for ether star pi minus
eta height pi in the height path is the
return on the virtual environment and it
has star pi
is the return on the real environment
the first step is to do some kind of
like telescoping sum
which i'm not going to explain in detail
and then um the test concept was instant
expectation is basically
a way to measure the differences between
t hat and t star
under the test function of v pi and then
you use the ipm definition and you
change that to ipm
and then you know that ipm is less than
the u of sa
and that's it so um
and then with this you know so the
configuration we can do a second step
and this is the model voice based policy
optimization with the reward penalty
recall that in the second set we are
trying to optimize pi
uh uh uh we are trying to optimize over
pi
the lower bound e to pi minus e of pi
and it turns out that because the form
of the e of pi the lower bound can be
written as this expectation
of r of x a minus lambda of u of s
just because what's you know under the
expectation are the same
so you can merge them together into a
single expectation and then you realize
that this is basically optimizing
uh uh uh the policy uh for
penalized mdp and tilde which is defined
to be having the same
learn dynamics t had and then the
penalized reward are tilde which is
penalized by lambda
times the answer implication of the
dynamics and then you just use some
off-the-shelf
r algorithm to optimize it
so and how do we implement the iso
multiplication for dynamics
uh in practice uh i i've thought about
this kind of like isolation for a while
in the last few years uh it turns out
that you know uh there are not so many
you know very good
ways to do iso convocation especially
under out of domain
shift for even surprise learning so what
we do is just a heuristic
we just use the ensemble to to do the
heuristic for
ufx so you take you know a sample of
models and
you look at the differences between the
output of these bottles
so um i guess i'm running
a little bit late so i'm going to also
skip this you know
um slice you know i kind of i started
you know the motivated talk by
talking about the trade-off between the
gains and the and the risk
of leaving bachelor support we can also
characterize that a little bit
um this is just a super simple extension
of the
of the theorem so basically you can
characterize what uh the property of the
policy you have
it's kind of like a doing some kind of
like trade-off between
uh taking uh the race of our uh
maximizing the uh
it just take uh it's trading off between
the uh having smaller
small risk and maximizing uh the return
so
here the um the policy is you know
larger than either star pi
minus 2 lambda times absolute pi
absolute pi is a way to measure
the risk and basically you are treating
all these two terms
i'm going to just skip some of this um
so um we did a bunch of
evaluation um uh you know either so this
paper is you know
even though there's some theory here
mostly it is about you know empirical
results
so we did an evaluation on the default
io data set which is a
recently collected you know um benchmark
data set for offline reinforcement
learning
and then we see that our results um uh
are better than some of the
best methods uh on uh bentofix
environments so here
the kind of environments we're doing
pretty well are those kind of so-called
mixed
or random environment meaning that here
the best data are from a mix of policy
or from random policy so
um it so we suspect that the reason is
that
we are doing well when the batch data
are somehow kind of like diverse
so this allows us to have a good
answering classification for dynamics
the dynamics can extrapolate outside the
support of the data
however if the batch data is not diverse
enough like in a medium which means that
you only have a single policy
in the batch that generates the batch
data and then
um the batch data is very kind of like a
low dimensional and the extrapolation of
the dynamics is not good so that's why
our method is not
as competitive as in other cases so we
also evaluate on those
on the so-called auto distribution
offline rl tasks that we designed
so this is to test whether our method is
doing well in those situations where
the agent has to take the risk of
leaving the support of the batch data
to achieve higher rewards so so we try
to design a task like this
so the batch data and the uh and
the task itself are somewhat different
so for example
one of the tasks is called an angle so
where the batch data
in the batch that ends only runs forward
on the right hand side to the right hand
side
however in a task you are supposed to
let the end
to go in a direction with degree 30. so
if you want to solve the task very well
then you have to
leave the batch data support to do um
leave the bachelor support to some
degree and the
sheet of jump is the same thing so
basically in the batch data
the cheat act is running forward but the
task requires the gtac to supposed to
uh to jump a little bit so you have to
leave the batch data
distribution so and we can see that our
you know uh advantage over prior work uh
is
in some sense kind of like a um
amplified partly because
the prior work are trying to stay in the
batch data distribution
okay so um um just uh the summary so
uh this talk is about offline model
based ro and the approach is that we
have a
reward county from the uncertain
quantification of the dynamics
and we just optimized the penalized
virtual
environment so some open questions
so one of the obvious open question is
that how do we do tighter and
signification
um so we have a way to do isolation
which is obviously not very tight
for many cases and how do we have
tighter isolating condition
and another question is related to some
of the questions
asked in a talk so uh how can we be
less conservative than optimizing the
lower confidence bond
so often the lower confidence bond
allows us to show that
you know the thing we are optimizing is
a lower bound for the real return
and that gives us some property however
potentially you know i don't know i'm
kind of torn by this
um but potentially there's a way to be
less conservative uh
uh than than doing this uh and i like to
spend just one minute to
have some advertisements for some of my
other iowa work
um uh in deep enforcement learning which
i spend a lot of time
uh these days you know thinking about
some of these questions so one of the
work
is uh we are studying uh the differences
between model base r and model 3 are
also the length of expressivity
so we show that in many in certain cases
the q function can be much more complex
to express than the model
itself which suggests that which kind of
like indicates model based is probably
uh have some advantage over model 3 in
this kind of cases
and also we are trying to address the
distribution of
distribution shift in math reinforcement
by using model based ideas as well
so i guess this is all i want to say i'm
running a little bit late
um thank you very much all right well
thank you very much
10 years so um i'm going to i have a few
questions but i'll actually leave the
audience to ask first i believe that
gergei you had a question about the
simulation lamas i'll let you ask it
directly in fact um and as a reminder we
also have
at 11 30 pacific time a larger
discussion of
planar el i mean we could focus on
technical details for the talks and come
back to
the broader discussion at 11 30. uh
gerger you want to go first
uh yeah sure thank you mark and thanks
thank you for the talk so
i was just wondering about this result
that relates the model estimation error
to the to the policy value error so is
this not the simulation lambda this is
just a simplification
oh i'm i'm not sure whether that's a
common word but you know but this is
just a simulation
we do a little bit on top of it by doing
the one system ipm thing
but you know but it's just a simulation
yes
right but when you for example when you
try to come up with confidence intervals
in terms of
what such time distance can you actually
like do this for any reasonable class of
models
or you're just using it as an abstract
example
um so if you uh i'm just using that as
an example but
um sorry can you say the last question
yeah so like can you can like derive
meaningful bounds on the wassenstein
distance
that would lead to like a reasonable
algorithm
um you know so um the what sustained
distance come
so so we are so after we got the volcan
distance
we assume that you have an arrow
estimator for the vastness and distance
and then there's nothing like everything
is folded in the assumption in some
sense
so basically so there's a lot of wishful
thinking in there
yeah yeah yeah that's right that's right
yeah so uh i guess tv distance is even
less
it's even more eligible thinking right
so right i don't think in reality you
can get a model
that can be accurate in tv distance that
sounds like very hard to achieve
yeah so uh so so yeah so that's just a
full demonstration yeah
the disclaimer is basically just a
simulation that's it all right
gotcha thanks very much thank you thank
you
okay are there other questions for
tenure
well this is not a really a question but
i thought that
one of the open problems is tighter
uncertainty quantification
i just wanted to point out that uh this
is um the
sum of talks on friday will talk about
uncertainty quantification so if people
are interested so
that would be uh something uh
interesting to look at thanks
looking forward to the time so
um go ahead so it seems like uncertainty
quantification
you know is certainly an important part
of what you're doing
and i was just wondering what your
experience was with using ensembles
because it seems like you know what
ensembles are really measuring is sort
of the
variance in your optimizer you know so
you can imagine the worst case you just
have an optimizer that completely
ignores the data
outputs exactly the same thing every
time you say you know great
zero epistemic uncertainty so uh how
much did you run into that in practice
so um i think we look at the uh the
error
the correlation between the ensemble ira
estimator
was the real uh uh error
surprisingly the the correlation is
pretty well so i think the
harder part is that what if you optimize
your policy based on that harassment
right so if you just take some
random policy or take some kind of like
fixed policy and you look at this
iso qualification by the ensembles
uh i think my uh my experiences says
that it seems that it's
generally pretty okay but however the
tricky part is that if you
do some optimization uh then you may
over fade to the ensemble you have
so so here we are pretty much
pessimistic we are taking the
uh one step error uh using our sample
and then we take the sum of the errors
right so that's what the telescoping or
the simulation level is doing
right so um so that seems to
reduce this issue a little bit so it's
very hard to kind of over
fit code overlay to the ensemble because
you are taking
the arrow for every stat and then you
take the sum um i'm not sure whether
that answer the question
so but generally i i don't really know
like a fall for us it seems to be okay
and also we have a
uh slightly different ways to do that
certification in the paper we have two
ways one way is that we can learn a
stochastic model actually
and you take the maximum of the variance
uh
across the five uh stochastic models
like
you learned and another way is you to
look at differences between the
disagreements between the ensembles and
both subnet works
pretty pretty fun one method works a
little better than the other
so um but yeah but but generally i don't
have much more
to say than this like uh it's pretty
empirical we just try
try try these things yeah yeah thanks
i want to ask a slightly leading
question but uh
maybe this this will be interesting to
discuss so
i'll just say one last question from you
and then we'll switch to emma thank you
um so uh you said that you need to do
uncertainty quantification
but i wonder if maybe the problem is
actually a little bit easier than that
because all that's really needed by the
algorithm is some
notion that this is like a bad place to
be and i wonder if that's actually
easier than uncertainty quantification
for
as an example so there's there's a
question in the q a about upper bounds
versus lower bounds and exploration
exploitation that got me thinking about
this
if you do count based exploration uh
that is kind of kind of estimating
uncertainty in a state but estimating
account
is easier than estimating epistemic
uncertainty on a model
so i wonder what your opinion is on
whether there's basically
an easier way that doesn't require the
full posterior
i see so yeah i guess so
i yeah i guess i don't
quite know so so this is you know this
is very um this is kind of like what i'm
asking i guess you know i'm not sure
exactly i'm interpreting the question
in the right way but this is kind of
like what i i was thinking
about less being less conservative uh
but on the other hand
i guess at least the thinking from a
theoretical perspective you know if
you're less conservative
then sometimes all myself like you i
don't have any guarantees so
so finding the right you know uh middle
middle ground
seems to be the the hardest part uh and
and also
i guess another maybe not answering
exactly a question so
but one question is how do we
extrapolate to
the unseen states right so if you want
to do well do you have to extrapolate as
much as possible to an
unseen state and which mechanism you are
trying to
you are relying on so are you relying on
the model to extrapolate or you are
relying on the queue function to
extrapolate
or you rely on something more kind of
like uh advanced to extrapolate that's
something
uh i assume it's also an interesting
open question
all right um don't you thank you so much
for this talk
it's exciting to see so much interest in
the topic and uh so many questions to
start
so let's